salut tout le monde sait squeeze on se
retrouve aujourd'hui pour une vidéo
explicative donc où je vous montre à peu
près les différents qu'il possible avec
un sniper parce qu'entre les flèches
copler scoop les quicks copley 360 les
titanic et tout le reste faut bien dire
on s'y retrouve vraiment pas bien donc
on commence tout de suite avec le quick
scope donc le vraiment le truc le plus
connu après les coupes
donc c'est simple vous essayez de mettre
le mec au milieu de la croix vous copé
et au moment où la croix à paris enfin
un petit peu après hop voyez bim vous
tirer c'est le style c'est beau et on
peut faire de beaux enchaînements on
enchaîne tout uteq le fleuve comme donc
c'est plus élaboré c'est à dire que à
peine lacroix a parlé on tue mec voire
même des fois on tire avant que lacroix
paraissent up love voyage vraiment bien
fait donc voilà le no scop donc là de la
pure chance si vous êtes chanceux les
noces coptes sont faits pour vous donc
là tous visés solide augmente vos
chances de réussir donc voilà le double
souci nos scoops c'est une variante
genoscope donc c'est à dire qu'on fait
un double switch et hop
juste après on tire en hausse comme
c'est beau c'est magique le titanic donc
on tirait juste après on met un couteau
de lancer c'est beau ce stylo re regarde
au ralenti la séquence
[Musique]
ajoutée au projet attaque à musique de
merde donc ensuite le drague
donc c'est simple vous ce copé vous
balayer en fait c'est un ballet aimant
et vous tirez au moment où le viseur
passe sur le mec c'est vraiment aussi
beau surtout sur console avec le pad ces
pratiques les 360 1 360 un cusco point
de scoop à l'arrivée c'est le style
c'est beau ça fait plaisir
il ya aussi des variantes du 360 comme
le 720 donc de retour sur soi le 1083
tour sur soi même le 1444 sur soi même
etc etc etc
il est aussi le 360 dans un sens 360
dans l'autre et on tue mais bon j'arrive
pas à les faire parce que je joue sur pc
je n'ai pas en pas donc c'est pas facile
voilà écoute et j'espère que cette vidéo
vous aura plu double cliquer sur j'aime
si si vous avez aimé
abonnez vous si vous aimez bien mais
vidéo enfin jeter un oeil à mes autres
vidéos et abonnez vous si vous aimez
bien ce que je fais et puis bah voilà
écouter des civils si vous laissez des
commentaires peut-être que je pourrai
envisager éventuellement de faire des
tutoriels mais comme je vous dis un tout
et dans cette vidéo il n'y a pas de
secret le secret c'est le timing est
ensuite faut s'entraîner un point c'est
tout et voilà allez ciao tout le monde
bail